[Music]
now as most of you know there continue
to be many problems or reports of
problems with the living conditions at
the Sochi Olympics here to comment on
all of this once again live from Russia
is the Sochi Olympics public relations
director Yuri Kamarov let's keep our
connections clear hello mr. Tanner ah
hello : it is most pleasurable for me to
again make your acquaintance can't talk
long though very busy ok well it's funny
you don't look very busy I upset hello
you can't believe how great the Olympics
are going no problems at all I am most
pleased that you informed me of that
right now at this moment ok Yuri Yuri
let's face it there are problems what
about and this is real all the dirty
brown tap water in people's hotel rooms
that's a picture that went viral what
about that brown wall thirties for
safety Konan safety is clear water gets
on floor low and can see it you're
tripping break man without water easy to
see next day in one piece like old
Russian proverb say water brown don't
fall down water clear there is no that's
rejected I never heard that saying he's
popular a Russian saying that
conveniently rhymes in English what's
that brown water and floor kept you
alive I am most pleased with the timing
of your call
okay what about this what about this big
pile of broken rubble in a hotel lobby
we'd have to say about that he's not
rubble is modern art installation
he's metaphor okay metaphor metaphor for
what for mankind's eternal struggle to
make our way through a hotel lobby full
of rope hello Guggenheim Art Museum
you want to buy hotel lobby metaphor
rubble better than Mona Lisa that's
great I'm sorry it's obvious that no
one's calling you your phone's not even
ringing well phone is on vibrate is
stupid that's an old phone it can't do
this very sophisticated new Russian
smartphone oh look I am getting a text
right now from my girlfriend she wants
sexy big hurry there's no way you can
deny the ongoing problems of stray dogs
everywhere stray dogs all over Sochi
those are not dogs
those are Olympic security guards
disguised as dogs Wow don't believe me
let's talk to the Olympic phone operator
right now yeah hello dog phone operator
what's that you want sexy dick pic -
okay you nasty [ __ ] stop it's okay it's
okay Conan this phone has a great data
plan unlimited sexting to dogs and bears
dogs and pairs yes yes it's true but you
have to be careful sometimes the Bears
get jealous